and finally new rule well we had a good
run
I know that's not really a rule but
since everything in America is about to
change in a very fundamental way what
the [ __ ]
rules are about to go out the window
Tuesday is election day and I know I
should probably tell you to vote and
what honest to God is really the most
important election ever so okay yes you
should vote and it should be for the one
party that still stands for democracy
preservation
but it's also a waste of breath because
anyone who believes that is already
voting and anyone who needs to learn
that isn't watching and no one in
America can be persuaded of anything
anymore anyway
the January 6th hearings it turns out
changed nobody's mind
Democrat Jamie Raskin said the hearings
would tell a story that will really blow
the roof off the house no that was
Hurricane Ian
the hearing's roof not blown the
committee did a masterful job laying out
the case but we live in partisan America
now so it's a little like doing stand up
when half the crowd only speaks Mandarin
no matter how good the material is it's
not going to go over
after all the hearings the percentage of
Americans who thought Trump did nothing
wrong went up three points that's
American now it's like trying to win an
argument in a marriage even when you're
right it still gets you nothing
foreign
Franklin said our country was a republic
if you can keep it well we can't
and unless a miracle happens on Tuesday
we didn't democracy is on the ballot and
unfortunately it's going to lose and
once it's gone it's gone
it's not something you can change your
mind about in Reverse that's gender
[Laughter]
so here's what's going to happen
Republicans will take control of
Congress and next year they'll begin
impeaching Biden and never stop they'll
impeach him for getting out of
Afghanistan and getting into Ukraine for
inflation for recession for falling off
his bike it won't matter and it won't
make sense but Biden will be a crippled
duck when he goes up against the 2024
Trump carry Lake ticket
and even if Trump loses it doesn't
matter on inauguration day 2025 he's
going to show up whether he's on the
list or not
and this time he's not going to take no
for an answer because this time he will
have behind him the army of election
deniers that is being elected in four
days
there are almost 300 candidates on the
ballot this year who don't believe in
ballots and they'll be the ones writing
the rules and monitoring how votes are
counted in 24. the facts the policies
the behavior don't matter anymore Trump
could be filmed throwing a baby off a
bridge and still win not to give
Herschel Walker any idea
[Applause]
this really is the Crossing the Rubicon
moment when the election deniers are
elected
which is often how countries slide into
authoritarianism not with tanks in the
streets but by electing the people who
then have no intention of ever giving it
back the Republican up for Wisconsin
governor just said if he's elected quote
Republicans will never lose another
election
this is how it happens Hitler was
elected so was Mussolini Putin erdogan
Victor Orban
this is the it can't happen to us moment
that's happening to us right now
we just don't feel it yet
we're the Titanic right after the
iceberg hit
and honestly too many Americans just
don't care and won't even care after it
happens because they never followed
politics to begin with and were never
taught in school what democratic
government was supposed to look like
so how sad can they be about losing
something they never knew they had
you can try and tell them that we will
no longer have a system of checks and
balances but they will have an answer
for that what's checks and balances
democracy is hard
Athens
didn't have to deal with Fox News or the
smartphone that made everybody stupid
and they only lasted 200 years so r246
doesn't look that bad
but before we do go
I'd like to say a little farewell to
some of the things that really did make
America great that now we're going to
lose forever
like the peaceful transfer of power
the jewel in our crown that thing that
so many other nations couldn't pull off
that we always did
oh well
the Bill of Rights
when there is no accountability at The
Ballot Box
there are no actual rights
look generalisimo Trump is not going to
bring back child labor or end Social
Security or re-segregate the water
fountains he doesn't hate Jews Ivanka is
a Jew and he loves her
now that she's 40 only as a friend but
still
but make no mistake it will be an
entirely different way of life for many
because our elections will just be for
show
like in China and Russia and all the
other places Trump says a very strong
free speech
well he's a man who's always taken
criticism well
but I wouldn't count on that one lasting
I wouldn't count on freedom of religion
lasting Q Anon and the other shock
troops of the Trump takeover of the
Republican Party are all quasi-religious
entities who want a Christian government
oh and the FBI might be replaced by an
army of proud boys under the leadership
of Michael Flynn
even something like pot will it stay
legal
it probably depends on whether Snoop
Dogg calls Trump brilliant one day I
mean that's
that's how things will be decided not by
the rule of law
ah
the rule of law that one was a real
Jewel yeah maybe our finest Hour As
Americans was after World War II when we
gave even the defeated Nazis a fair
trial
Justice Robert Jackson said that
voluntarily submitting our captive
defeated enemies to the rule of law
was one of the most significant tributes
that power had ever paid to reason
well power will very soon not be paying
any more tributes to Reason Not In
America anyway
so yeah I urge you to vote but I've
always been a realist
I'm afraid democracy is like the McRib
it's here now it'll be around for a
little bit longer so enjoy it while you
can